I'm gonna start scooping Oh stick your
chopsticks that you stick in your mouth
write it up Ryan look at this
well you just stuck your saliva yeah so
today we are here at bungalow chunk in
Koreatown Los Angeles
yeah cream feels good I think that's
probably the most general most
agreed-upon statement of all time so I
don't know too much about Korean food
but I know Korean barbecue is long I
frankly have no idea what this is you're
doing the only yellow food I know is a
banana that's the only yellow food you
know look at that look at the layers on
this thing the fish drive-ins alright
this the little hint of saltiness is the
fish egg oh hello spice Hotlanta that's
amazing and you're like fits perfectly
in your mouth it's not the biggest egg
guy I gotta be honest I love eggs I
could just hold that up and slide them
into my mouth I cook the whole thing
right now this is really satisfying ten
seconds I just finished my first one I
don't know my second one no let me push
up is this a full little octopus yeah
it's a half did have a like a brother or
something could I eat at the same time
oh I'm gonna take that whole thing it's
Korean bacon right here
mmm I'm really truly oh boo boo a local
farmer I know you're not a fan of spice
so it surprises me that you actually
like this but it is done in a way that
contributes to the flavors you would
think pork and octopus would be like a
weird combo but I think a complement to
each other really well you can't eat
this and still be cute it makes sense
that you'd eat these things at a bar
when you stop caring so we got our spicy
chicken we got our rice cakes and we
have cheese that's gonna melt it's like
some awesome palmview fondue for two
please wait that's it's pink why is it
pink underneath what is it I mean those
science hmm
I love so good it is the right amount of
spice cuz I'm a baby when it comes to
spice you are you're like a little baby
or hey alright you don't have to you
have the tongue and tolerance of a
toddler I have the tongue of a toddler
yeah oh look at that cheesy goodness
this is what I like to see I feel like
this taste is what inspired the oh yes
on tasty you're really going to town in
that cheese so it's good cheese again
not necessarily a date food they know
what works and then they just they go
for it oh my god so good you run that's
right now
clearly you're enjoying this yeah if I
was drunk and I was eating this it'll be
a complete disaster yeah this is a whole
nother side to Korean food that I was
not aware of his rich savory I could see
myself eating this at 2:00 a.m. after a
long night
I've been enlightened by this new Korean
food today and I'm just like what is
going on I want more of this
[Music]
[Music]